What is your favorite methyl B12 for someone with high hobosistine?
Now, the reason that person asked that question is that I typically don't recommend
methyl-methylated vitamins, methyl-lated B12, methyl-lated folic acid folate.
With somebody with cancer because methyl groups can turn off tumor suppressor genes and
can cause the cancer to grow. But if a person, the caveat to that is if a person has high hobosistine.
So if a person has high hobosistine, they need to take methyl B12 or methyl-folate.
So what's the good brand? Well, this is one of those going back to the question I just spoke about,
about how do you know if you have a good supplement or a bad supplement.
Well, if it's methyl-methyl-combolivine,
methyl-combolivine is methyl-combolivine. So it doesn't really make any difference when
brand you're getting it from. If it's the methyl-lated folate, it's methyl tetrahedral folate. You'll see
that as, it might even say folic acid, which is, which folic acid is a synthetic folate. So you
never, nobody should take folic acid. But still some good companies still list something as folic acid
because they know that the general population is too ignorant to know what folate is. So they still
list the old name folic acid. But then it may say folic acid as methyl tetrahedral folate. Okay,
so that's the good source of folate. But usually it should properly be labeled folate as methyl-tetrahedral
folate. So that would be the correct form of folate in the correct form of B12. If a person
as high homocysteine is taking methyl-tetrahedral folate and methyl-combolivine, brand really doesn't
matter with that.